hey everybody welcome back to the
stronger by science podcast my name is
Eric Trexler I'm going to be your one
and only host for today's show uh you
might notice if you're a long time
listener that my voice sounds pretty bad
today uh the reality is as we've talked
about in previous episodes unappreciated
and underpaid labor sustains my podcast
but to be honest it also sustains my
physical health and so as this strike
this totally illegal strike by the
stronger by science podcast co-host
Union continues
um my physical health is deteriorating
at a very rapid and very alarming rate
um so just to give an update on where
we're at there uh previously the union
requested contact to be reinstated with
family and friends I made a concession
there and allowed that then they wanted
Christmas day off in the future uh once
again I made another very generous
concession and uh you know part of that
was generosity another part was I'm
getting a lot of very unfair bad press
in the YouTube comments and the Facebook
group so shame on the individuals who
are being very rude to me there uh so I
made these concessions and I only
implemented very modest pay reductions
in order to offset some of the severe
damages that the podcast would incur
from those concessions but unfortunately
the greed and the treachery of this
Union knows no bounds they have now
requested
a private jet for the Union uh so I got
that request and it caught me off guard
I will admit uh so when I get caught off
guard I have a team meeting with my
lawyer and my accountant just to kind of
get my bearings my lawyer tells me that
a hundred percent of this Union actually
lives in the city where the podcast is
filmed and produced so I don't know
where they're flying to
um and so then I chat with my accountant
my accountant tells me that there has
never been a single documented instance
of approved business travel for the
podcast they also told me that if I buy
a brand new Gulfstream jet that is going
to burn through at least two full months
of the podcast budget uh so I talked
with the Union I say listen let's make a
deal here I will Charter a private
flight Whenever there is business
related travel you just gotta you know
get the business travel approved I'll
Charter the flight you won't have to fly
commercial uh they immediately turn that
down they are insisting that they want
to actually own the aircraft itself uh
so you know I'm very generous I'm a very
altruistic man uh I give and I give and
I give
uh but even I have limits okay so I
thought we were at an impasse previously
I'm feeling worse than ever about where
we're at with the Union uh and it is
alarming I'm very concerned about the
deterioration of the show and I'm I'm
very concerned about the deterioration
of my physical health which is uh
obviously visually apparent and you can
hear it as well so I am falling apart
but I will continue to push forward very
bravely so before we dive into today's
content
uh there are many ways to support the
show if you like it and as you can hear
from the way the strike is going we need
your support more than ever uh you can
like rate or subscribe wherever you get
the podcast you can sign up for a
newsletter at strongerbyscience.com
newsletter and if you do sign up you're
going to get our research Spotlight
email so let's go out every Wednesday
and give you a really nice concise
update on some new research in the world
of exercise and nutrition if you're
looking for a one-on-one virtual coach
we do offer that as well you can learn
more at strongerbyscience.com coaching
if you're looking for a discount on your
supplements you can go to
bulksupplements.com they have a wide
variety of great products and you can
use the discount code SBS pod to get
five percent off your order you could
subscribe to the mass research review
which gives you a really comprehensive
research update every single month and
you can check out macro Factory that is
the diet app that Greg and I created
along with a very talented team of
colleagues uh we think you're going to
love it which is why we offer a free
trial you can try it out see if you love
it and hopefully you will and you'll
stick with it so macro Factor you can
learn more at macro factorapp.com or you
can just search it in the app stores
all right so before I get into the new
content for today's episode I want to
address uh three questions or provide a
few uh clarifications I guess based on
listener feedback and based on uh some
chatter in the groups uh so by the way
if you're not a member uh we have a
subreddit for Stronger by science and we
also have a Facebook group which is
called Stronger by science Community if
you're not already a member of one or
both you should check them out a really
really good communities uh very
supportive group of people and some
really good conversation uh going on in
those groups so be sure to check them
out
so I want to address three things first
of all someone asked why there's a bunch
of bulls behind me and they kind of look
like those things that you might use to
grind something up into a fine powder
that's not what they are they're
referring to these you can see a variety
of them behind me so these are not for
grinding powders these are singing bowls
uh so over the last couple years I have
been reading and studying a lot about uh
about Buddhism and of course with
Buddhism there there's a lot of
different types of meditation and
sometimes people in certain schools or
traditions of Buddhism will enjoy using
these singing bowls as part of
meditative practice so
when you strike the ball with the uh the
Mallet that comes with it it makes a
very nice tone
um and it can kind of facilitate a level
of relaxation and focus as you listen to
the tone and uh and you know do perhaps
like a sitting uh meditation some type
of mindfulness meditation so uh these
types of bowls are common in certain
types of Buddhism and they are I think
they're very pretty and very lovely they
make a nice sound and the question about
why there are so many is because much
like any percussive instrument
the size and shape can impact the
specific tone that is produced uh and so
for that reason it's common to get an
entire set with each Bowl having a
slightly different shape and slightly
different size and so then you have
different tones that are created uh when
you strike them so that is what the
bowls are all about and that actually is
relevant to Today's Show because we are
going to talk a little bit about mindful
eating which is an offshoot of General
mindfulness as a concept which has a lot
of roots in Buddhist practice so if
you're asking why I have these
like I said Each one has a different
tone and based on the physics of sound
waves you could say that they very
literally set different vibes okay so
number two a little clarification in a
previous episode I was talking about it
was it was I believe part two of my
series on uh popular diets and common
misconceptions in nutrition uh I called
olive oil a vegetable oil
here's the thing about olives they're
not vegetables uh olives are technically
a fruit and something that I learned
recently is that cucumbers are also a
fruit uh I am not a fruit denier but I
will say if I consume something and it's
not very sweet it's hard or citrusy it's
hard for me to call it a fruit I just
kind of mentally file it away as
something else so uh yeah like I said
olives not a vegetable very much a fruit
um and I appreciate the listener for
pointing that out
sometimes you sit in front of a camera
for 90 minutes two hours and uh you
misspeak and you miscategorize so uh I
always appreciate when people Point
those things out and then I can clarify
on the show what I was doing there
though is I was talking about the
Mediterranean diet which tends to be
very high in olive oil uh or olive oil
is really a featured food that is kind
of front and center when you talk about
the Mediterranean diet and in that
episode I wanted to not just talk about
popular diets but also address really
common or really popular misconceptions
in nutrition
now Mediterranean diet is a bit of an
outlier in the sense that when you
compare it to the other diets that are
frequently recommended by health
organizations it tends to be a little
higher in fat than the others and that
fat is mostly coming from plant-based
oils so olive oil is one but you'll find
some other plant-based oils in there as
well and what I wanted to do is use the
Mediterranean diet as a jumping off
point so I could address some common
misconceptions about plant-based oils
and more specifically seed oils so you
know you can kind of broadly talk about
plant-based oils you could focus even
even further on vegetable based oils
and then you can focus even closer on
seed oils and so there's a lot of uh
negativity on the internet about seed
oils right now that I think is
ill-advised and not quite accurate okay
so I wanted to to at least address some
of those misconceptions and in the
process I miscategorized olives as
vegetables that was my mistake uh okay
the last thing I want to mention here
um back in episode 107. I was talking
about
I believe self-determination Theory and
different types of motivation
so
in that process I talked about
intrinsic motivation being a very high
quality form of motivation
and so there was a question in the
stronger by science Community Facebook
group and The Listener basically said I
was listening to episode 107 lots of
hype about intrinsic motivation
I got diagnosed with ADHD this year and
one of the big Revelations I've noticed
is how much extrinsic factors can help
keep me on track so is all of this
intrinsic motivation research done on
neurotypical people and and then a kind
of a secondary question does it apply to
people who are neurodivergent or
neurodiverse that was an excellent
question and a very excellent discussion
in the Facebook group about it so
there's a few things I want to mention
here first of all
it was not my intention to suggest that
purely intrinsic motivation is the only
good source of motivation nor did I
intend to imply that extrinsic
motivation is totally useless so the
working consensus of the literature is
that generally speaking motivation
quality increases as it becomes more
intrinsic in nature and another way to
frame that is as the perceived locus of
causality becomes more internal
we tend to see that the general quality
of the motivation goes up
um so there are many different forms of
extrinsic motivation and so you could
even look within the category of
extrinsic motivation divided up into
several subtypes and kind of put them on
a spectrum
of which of these extrinsic for types of
motivation are more intrinsic in nature
I know that sounds like an oxymoron but
we can kind of align them on a spectrum
based on things like the perceived locus
of causality whether that's internal or
external so I'm going to put a link in
the show notes where you can look at
this spectrum of motivation quality as
posited by self-determination Theory but
it starts with a motivation a complete
lack of motivation
and then on the other end of the
spectrum kind of highest quality is
purely intrinsic motivation and then in
between there are several forms of
extrinsic motivation and as you go up
the Spectrum and go to higher and higher
and higher quality levels you see that
the uh the extrinsic forms of motivation
become more intrinsic in nature so they
aren't what we would call intrinsic
motivation but they are getting closer
um and so for example
um
you know just to give an idea
um you could you know there are a an
example I mentioned in the uh in the
podcast originally was about just doing
your homework or doing an assignment for
for school or for you know a university
course or whatever you know there are
some kids who will you know just say I'm
gonna do this homework assignment
because if I don't I'm going to get
yelled at I'm going to get in trouble
whatever right so that uh perceived
locus of causality is very external
right you're just doing something so
that someone else won't get mad at you
and they're the person who's determining
what you do uh when you do it how you do
it and you know indirectly why you do it
right because if they weren't telling
you to do it you never would do it in
the first place you're just doing it to
appease them and to avoid punishment
right
so that certainly falls under the
umbrella of extrinsic motivation but you
could also look at doing a homework
assignment or an assignment for a
university course and say you know I
don't love this assignment I'm not doing
this because I'm interested in it
because I enjoy it because it brings me
any level of inherent satisfaction
but I do intrinsically understand that
this is good for me like I believe that
doing this assignment is in my best
interest not for avoiding punishment but
for learning this material so I can get
into the major that I want to study get
the degree I want enter the career I
want so again you're not doing it for
purely intrinsic factors
it is still a force or a a type of uh
extrinsic motivation that's kind of
forcing you toward the decision to
actually do it
um but but we can see with Under the
Umbrella of extrinsic motivation that
can look very very different one of
those scenarios there are much more
intrinsic factors at play compared to
the other so doing something to avoid
punishment is very different from doing
something because you believe it's in
your best interest even though there are
still you know there's still some
extrinsic motivation going on in that
scenario so that's one thing second
thing
um the second thing I want to address is
the question
um kind of a two-part question
this motivation research first of all is
it mostly done in people who are
neurotypical or who are not
neurodivergent and you know by extension
to what extent does this apply to people
who are neurodivergent
um so
it is true that the vast majority of
this motivation research is done using
study participants who are not
neurotypical or do not have any type of
neurodivergence that that has been
diagnosed so I do not reference This
research to be exclusionary in nature I
certainly don't reference it to diminish
or downplay the importance
of understanding motivation processes in
neurodivergent individuals you know this
is important to me I mean I I have a
condition that I believe is broadly
considered a form of of neurodivergence
uh I have Tourette Syndrome uh diagnosed
at the age of two so that's kind of been
a common thing in my life is kind of
taking the generalizable advice and then
saying okay but how does that actually
apply to me given that I have this form
of neurodivergence so that's been a a
theme throughout my entire life and I've
even I've coached a lot of
neurodivergent individuals as well uh
when I was working with the Special
Olympics as a strength coach I did that
for like five or six years I say working
I was I was a volunteer coach
um but yeah we had a lot of athletes who
were neurodivergent and so we we were
kind of uh constantly at top of Mind was
the question of you know what is the
most generalizable way you would coach
this but then step two is how would you
modify that for a particular form of
neurodivergence based on the individual
athlete
um so it is common for researchers to
begin studying a topic by allocating
their effort toward understanding the
topic in the most generalizable context
possible and then later the field will
try to refine that understanding so it
can be applied to less generalizable
circumstances so for example getting
away from motivation and just talking
about human movement
you know uh there's a lot of research
that's been done trying to understand
neuromuscular control how humans
navigate movement of the body and a lot
of that research uh is done in people
who do not have any neuromuscular
conditions or deficits so the idea is in
the most generalizable sense possible
let's get an understanding of
neuromuscular control so that we can
build out the theories and have this
basic template of understanding and then
later we will translate that information
so that we can understand the
differences that we observe in people
who have things like Parkinson's disease
or ischemic brain injuries that that
influence movement or really any other
medical state that can alter
neuromuscular control so
a lot of This research and motivation a
lot of the theory building research does
uh does take place in the context of
populations who are neurotypical or who
are not neurodivergent
um and hopefully we will have a lot more
research in the future that builds upon
this and refines it so that we can say
okay we understand the working theory of
motivation in neurotypical individuals
but for each specific type of
neurodivergent condition how do we then
adjust or adapt that theory in a way
that is more tailored and individualized
to the specific form of neurodivergence
because
um I would speculate that we're not
going to be able to say here's how
motivation works for neurotypical people
and here's how it works for people with
very with any type of neurodivergence
you know the way that the basic
underlying theory is refined and
adjusted is probably going to to be
specific specific to the exact form of
neurodivergence that that's being
discussed the third thing I want to
mention here is
um
in that thread it became clear that
there was some degree of
misunderstanding about extrinsic
motivation versus extrinsic support
systems so for example
I lean very heavily on my girlfriend to
hold me accountable to my goals uh but
but that is not necessarily
purely extrinsic motivation that is an
extrinsic support system so I set the
goals because I believe they're
important and I believe that they're in
my best interest I mean the goals that
I'm setting are motivated by very
intrinsic factors but I'm relying on
social support as an extrinsic support
system to help me stay on track with
those goals so the motivation is pretty
intrinsic in nature but there are some
external support systems in place to
help me stay on track so I wouldn't call
all of my goals to I wouldn't say that
they're all driven by purely intrinsic
motivation but they are pretty near the
intrinsic side of that motivation
Spectrum but when we talk about this
social support for example we could say
that that falls under the relatedness
category of self-determination Theory or
we could also put it under the
opportunity category of the combi model
of behavior change so what we're trying
to do is
use or I wouldn't say use we want to
create and lean on a a type of
environment that is supportive to what
we're trying to achieve and that can be
very helpful with accountability with
habit formation so having external
sources of support does not mean that
you are relying on Purely extrinsic
motivation there is a difference there
and I just mentioned how those things
would fit into self-determination Theory
and the combi model of behavior change
if you have no idea what I'm talking
about when I when I reference those be
sure to check out episode 107 which
discusses both of those in detail it'll
help contextualize how I kind of
categorize those things uh and then the
fourth thing I want to mention very very
simple
if external sources of support or even
extrinsic motivation help you make big
strides toward goals that are fulfilling
and productive for you and they make you
a happier and a healthier person I think
that's fantastic okay so as an
evidence-based content creator my goal
is to convey the most generalizable
evidence possible rather than just kind
of prioritizing my experience
in spite of the conclusions that we see
in the scientific literature so if
someone asked me you know hey talk about
intrinsic and extrinsic motivation I'm
going to go to the research I'm not just
going to say you know what I do this and
it works for me so the idea there is we
want to find research so that we can
draw conclusions that are the most
generalizable conclusions based on the
science but there are definitely some
psychological Concepts where I can
acknowledge that the scientific
consensus is something and then my
personal experience seems to be
something else right so there are things
in the psychology literature
that I can acknowledge as being the
scientific consensus while also
acknowledging that they aren't the best
fit for my personal psychological
profile so whenever I find myself in
that situation I just keep doing the
stuff that works for me while
understanding that I might be a bit of
an outlier or or just to be less extreme
with my language I might just be a bit
of an exception to the norm I you know
the the thing that works for most people
might not be the best thing for me and I
can accept that but when I create
content I don't want to say you know I
know that the science says this but my
personal experience is different so I'm
just going to go with what works for me
when I'm making content but in my
day-to-day life I am going to be
applying a mixture of I lean on the
evidence to figure out what seems to
work for most people but in my
day-to-day life I'm constantly refining
that and tailoring it to my own
experience so when I'm really at a loss
and I don't know where to begin I go to
the research I try Things based on the
scientific of a consensus but then over
time you start to get an idea of what
works for you and what doesn't so the
what I would encourage is you know if
you're listening to some of that content
about
goal setting motivation Behavior change
and you're saying you know what I
understand that the science says that
but it just doesn't work for me uh the
reason that we're doing this is to find
things that that work for us right so so
you should always value your own
personal experience and and Implement
things that seem to be working for you
in a really productive way so if
extrinsic motivation is helping you make
these big strides towards your goals you
know you're happier you're healthier
you're more fulfilled when you're using
these forms of extrinsic Motivation by
all means that's what you should be
doing uh all right so let's move on to
the nutrition content for today's
episode the two things I want to talk
about here are diet tracking and mindful
eating so we're going to start with diet
tracking because you know we are
it's January and so people are really
getting excited and enthusiastic about
their goals for the new year a lot of
folks are getting into diet tracking for
the first time in a while maybe the
first time ever or they're at least
considering getting into diet tracking
and there are a lot of questions about
it a lot of misconceptions so I want to
talk about diet tracking more broadly
and one of the first questions that
comes up with diet tracking you know
calorie tracking macro tracking Etc or
just keeping a a plain old food diary
one of the questions that comes up is
does Diet tracking work
um and the answer is it kind of depends
uh because diet tracking is an act of
description okay so you could
track diet habits that are very
incompatible with your goals so you're
doing diet tracking but when you look
down at the information you say what I'm
eating you know my eating habits right
now are not at all compatible with what
I'm trying to achieve
if you're tracking those habits but you
don't do anything with the information
you're not making any adjustments to
your behaviors or your nutritional
intakes uh you're you're not going to be
making successful strides towards your
goals just by describing actions that
are not compatible with your goals right
so if you are DOT tracking your diet but
you're not doing anything with the
information
uh you're finding that you know your
your dietary practices are incompatible
with your goals
and you're just continuing to document
that that contradiction that's really
not going to take you any closer to
those goals uh but diet tracking can be
very very useful even though it's nearly
an act of description so for example uh
it's very possible a common observation
is a lot of people don't realize that
their dietary habits were actually super
incompatible with their goals uh there
are a lot of people who start tracking
for the first time and say whoa I had no
idea that my intakes were so
incompatible with what I'm trying to
achieve here so in that scenario diet
tracking can help you learn that and it
can help you make the decision to adjust
your diet accordingly
um another instance where diet tracking
can be helpful is
sometimes people really like to have
tangible confirmation that they are on
track with what they're trying to
achieve so you know sometimes people
will want to continue tracking
consistently just so they can be more
confident that on a day-to-day
week-to-week month-to-month basis they
are continuing to eat in a way that is
fully compatible with the goals that
they've set for themselves if there are
some people who
um you know if they stop tracking they
feel like they lose
they lose a sense of understanding of
whether or not they are truly staying on
track with their dietary goals and so
for them having the objective data to
lean on
brings a source of confidence and
comfort where they can look at their
intakes and say I know I'm staying on
top of this I know that I'm staying on
track so
tracking works for a few different
things you know dietary tracking makes
you more aware of your dietary habits it
helps you monitor your dietary habits
and it empowers you to implement and
adjust a set of dietary strategies or
dietary habits that ultimately can bring
you closer to your goals so those are
the things that tracking really helps
with it's not that tracking
automatically is going to you know do
something that revolutionizes your
Fitness or your physique or your health
but it it gives you the information you
need to take that next step where you
become more aware of your dietary habits
and intakes you're now actively
monitoring those habits and intakes and
now you feel very empowered and informed
so that you can actually adjust those
habits and intakes and make them more
compatible more in line with the goals
that you've set and so that is in theory
what tracking ought to do and the
research generally Bears out the
efficacy of of diet tracking so when we
look at the research it often shows that
self-monitoring is an important
predictor of successful weight loss and
long-term maintenance after weight has
been lost so self-monitoring you might
be wondering what that term specifically
means two very helpful forms of
self-monitoring include weight tracking
and diet tracking okay so
self-monitoring is exactly what it
sounds like monitoring oneself when we
talk about uh goals pertaining to
fitness body composition Health two of
the most common things to self-monitor
would be body weight and nutritional
intake so when we look at the research
keeping tabs on changes in body weight
and keeping tabs on your diet intakes
and your diet habits those seem to be
pretty consistent predictors of
successful outcomes
and even more more practically speaking
um or I guess more anecdotally speaking
uh several years back I was working on a
study
um that was being done in conjunction
with a weight loss center so this this
weight loss center was helping people
lose weight not not doing you know
little eight-week crash diets but really
sustainable long-term weight loss with
frequent office visits you know this was
long-term sustainable weight loss so it
was the entire focus of this uh this
program and this Center and I would be
in the laboratory and people would come
back for these uh repeated visits uh for
for data collection
and obviously in any weight loss trial
some people are going to have a
tremendous amount of set of success and
some people are going to struggle much
more than others you know they're
they're going to be divergences in
outcomes and one of the things that
really struck me was the more I talked
with the individuals who were really
excelling in this program the people who
were losing tremendous amounts of weight
and keeping it off for very long
stretches of time uh one of one of the
really striking observations was that
they were pretty much all telling me the
same thing where I would sit down and
just say how are you doing this like
like you know because I can see relative
to their peers that they are really
excelling and one of the most common
things they would tell me is
I just track stuff I track my body
weight I track my diet if I notice that
my calories are creeping up with my
dietary intakes I see it early before I
gain a bunch of weight and I can I can
Rectify that I can correct that if I see
that my weight is creeping up that is an
indicator sometimes okay now I need to
look at my diet and see why that might
be the case you know where are these
extra calories coming from or perhaps
maybe my physical activity level has
dropped and I need to adjust my diet to
offset that but without question it was
it was a really clear thing the more I
talked to these folks self-monitoring
can be an extremely powerful tool and
diet tracking is a particular
particularly useful form of
self-monitoring now as I said before uh
diet tracking calorie counting it can be
very very helpful very informative very
effective for achieving a variety of
health and fitness related goals however
just tracking your diet is is not going
to guarantee success you need to
actually use the information that you're
getting but you also need to make sure
that you're tracking your diet
effectively
um if there are big sources of error in
your approach to diet tracking it's
going to limit your ability to
effectively use the information that
you're getting from that tracking
process so Greg wrote an excellent
article about some of the the most
common errors that can derail a person's
efforts with calorie counting or Diet
tracking because it's not uncommon to
hear people say I tried diet tracking
and calorie counting and it didn't work
for me and I think when you hear that
it's important to uh to dig into that a
little bit and explore where things
might have gone wrong because calorie
counting just based on uh laws of
physics it should work but but there are
many places where we can have sources of
error and you know issues with adherence
and things like that there are ways it
can go wrong for sure
so um I'm going to link great Greg's
article in the notes for today's show if
you want to read it I I would encourage
people to read it it's very very good
but I want to briefly mention some of
the biggest uh challenges or sources of
error when it comes to calorie counting
uh number one is just aiming for a fixed
calorie Target that is a
one-size-fits-all target so you might
find websites that say if you're a
biological female you should aim for
1200 calories a day when you're losing
weight and if you're a biological male
you know aim for 1500 calories per day
the issue is that those numbers will be
good for some people and terrible for
others
um it's it's virtually impossible to
make that type of
one-size-fits-all recommendation if the
goal is to promote sustainable weight
loss at an appropriate rate some people
are going to need a higher calorie
Target some are going to be lower and we
can't just give the same number to
everybody
or you know the same number to everybody
who shares the same biological sex
um there are a lot of factors that
influence an individual's energy needs
and so if you're using a fixed Target
for for daily calorie intake
um it might not be appropriate for you
and if you're using the wrong if you
have a if you're using the wrong calorie
Target that's not appropriate for you
obviously that is going to hinder
progress in a pretty significant way uh
number two using activity trackers to
determine energy needs so some people
will say I'm not going to use a generic
one-size-fits-all calorie recommendation
I'm going to use some type of wearable
technology like a watch to track my
daily energy expenditure and I'm going
to use that number to set my calorie
Target for whatever my goal happens to
be weight loss weight maintenance weight
gain the issue there is that a lot of
these activity trackers are really not
precise and they they don't have the
necessary reliability and validity to
actually use them for that purpose they
are they are not generally accurate
enough to give you a calorie Target that
you can feel very very confident in for
your fitness goals so
I don't want to say that those types of
trackers are not useful at all they are
useful for a number of things so one of
the things that they're very good for is
tracking heart rate they seem to do a
very good job with heart rate they seem
to do a pretty good job with step counts
as well so these types of wearable
devices they're getting better over time
but they're still really not I wouldn't
even consider them to be close in terms
of being able to use them to determine
uh you know what your calorie Target
should be for a given rate of weight
gain or weight loss or weight
maintenance
um they're they're very nice if you like
to monitor your heart rate or monitor
your step count but if you're using a an
activity tracker to set your daily
calorie Target it very well could Lead
You astray and ultimately hinder your
your progress number three a third major
source of error that could lead to
people saying hey I tried calorie
counting and it didn't work
um that would be using a fairly generic
calorie calculator right so I mentioned
what we're trying to do when we're
setting a calorie Target is figure out
how many calories do you burn every day
and therefore how many calories should
you eat every day to create a caloric
deficit or a caloric Surplus or whatever
you're trying to do
um so obviously using a single one size
fits-all number like 1200 calories
that's not going to be sufficiently
individualized using an activity tracker
like I said there's too much error
associated with the number that you're
getting it cannot really at this point
the current generation of trackers of
activity trackers cannot really give you
a a number or a calorie Target that you
have a high level of confidence in
there's just too much error to rely on
it for that specific purpose in my
opinion and then number three
um if you're using a calorie calculator
you might input uh things like your age
biological sex height weight uh BMI or
body fat percentage there are a variety
of different calculators that use
validated equations from research where
you put in some basic demographic
characteristics and it tells you okay
based on what you put in here we believe
that your daily energy expenditure is
you know 1900 calories right
so there are many of these calculators
that exist
they're better than just using a
one-size-fits-all number
but these these types of validated
equations they work very well they work
pretty well at the population level but
when you're trying to make an
individualized assessment of energy
expenditure they're simply not precise
enough for that purpose
um the when we look at how well these
equations estimate energy expenditure
they do a pretty good job if we're
trying to get the average energy
expenditure of a group of 3 000 people
but when we're talking about a specific
person you know the question is what
predictors are these equations actually
using in order to give a calorie Target
and the best one they could use is fat
free Mass so the amount of fat free mass
that you have is going to be the single
biggest predictor of your resting energy
expenditure so ideally you're going to
be using something that first of all is
based on fat free Mass but second of all
it's going to incorporate your physical
activity habits with some type of
correction factor the problem is fat
free mass is not uh a perfect predictor
of resting energy expenditure it's far
from perfect two people with the same
exact amount of fat free Mass could have
very very different resting energy
expenditure
and then you're going to be multiplying
that by a physical activity correction
factor and those are very imprecise
um it can be difficult to know exactly
what correct trim Factor you should be
using especially with the classic set
that is most popular they kind of merge
non-exercise and structured exercise
activity into one General thing for
physical activity which I think is
difficult to justify and very confusing
to implement but in many cases you know
sometimes people choose the wrong
activity correction factor for them
and even if they choose the right one uh
these correction factors are not precise
enough to give a truly individualized
estimate that will be highly tailored to
the individual so these types of calorie
calculators are a good starting point
but you really do need to refine the
estimate from there and they don't offer
the level of individualization that you
would consider sufficient for long-term
um tracking or calorie Target purposes
and then another thing to keep in mind
is
you know even if you get a very good
Target to begin with whether you're
gaining weight or losing weight energy
expenditure does tend to change pretty
considerably over time and so even if
you start with a perfect calorie Target
from using one of these uh calorie
calculators over time it will become
less perfect and it will become more
unsuitable for your goal and there's no
built-in mechanism to actually account
for that
um and and what there's a recent paper
by Rodriguez and colleagues out of Grant
Tinsley's lab I've mentioned it on the
show before what they found was that
these um validated equations do they do
okay when we just take someone at a you
know at their natural kind of typical
body weight they're at neutral energy
balance not gaining or losing any weight
at the time these equations do okay
uh specifically for resting energy
expenditure but as those individuals
start to gain or lose weight there are
going to be some adaptive changes in
their their resting energy expenditure
as it's measured in the lab and the
equations do a very poor job of actually
capturing that adaptive change uh so
these types of uh equation-based
estimates these calorie calculator
estimates for your energy needs
at Baseline they could be okay they
could be kind of bad for you because
they're not sufficiently individualized
but even if they start out really good
for you they will probably have a
tendency to get worse over time as your
energy expenditure changes so
in summary diet tracking can be a very
very helpful and very very effective
tool for achieving your fitness goals or
your health related goals but it works
best when you're approaching it the
right way so you need to actually do
something with the information from your
diet tracking and when you reach that
step of doing something with it you need
to make sure that you are aiming for a a
set of nutritional targets that is
actually individualized and appropriate
for you so now I want to talk about a
few things you can do to make diet
tracking as effective and as enjoyable
as possible first of all
I would encourage people to go back and
listen to past episodes of the podcast
about goal setting motivation and
behavior change uh I think those help
people in my opinion
develop and establish a very good mental
framework for how diet tracking is going
to fit into their overarching goal
hierarchy and how they can set
themselves up to sustain motivation and
persistent changes to their behavior you
know if you just Dive Right into diet
tracking but you don't have a good
mental framework for why you're doing it
and how you're going to do it I think
it's very possible that the whatever
success you uh experience there could
potentially be short-lived so if you
want to maximize your ability to set
yourself up for Success you want to do
some serious thinking about goal setting
motivation and behavior change number
two you want to use a tool that can
actually help you refine your diet
targets effectively
um so that you're aiming for targets
that are right for you uh so like I said
there are many different strategies that
people use that lead to a relatively
generic or poorly individualized calorie
targets and ultimately this is going to
um really threaten the utility of diet
tracking um you know diet tracking is
great for helping you see what you're
doing and equipping you with the ability
to make changes so that your diet will
be more individualized to your needs and
be more compatible to your goals so you
want to use tools that can help you
um you know refine your diet targets
your calorie targets and macro targets
uh the most effective way possible that
so that your diet is as individualized
and personalized and customized as it
can possibly be so obviously
I'm very biased but we at the stronger
by science podcast recommend macro
Factor as a tool that if you're just
starting out it can use estimates to get
you started with the best possible
General estimate for your calorie needs
based on your goal and your
characteristics but very quickly over
time over the first two or three weeks
it's going to use your body weight data
and nutrition data to really refine its
understanding of your daily energy
expenditure so that you can get a
calorie Target and a set of macro
targets
that will be very very compatible with
your goals in terms of your your rate of
weight loss what you're trying to
achieve and it'll also be compatible
with your preferences in terms of what
types of dietary
preferences you gravitate toward you
know whether you like more carbohydrate
more fat higher protein lower protein
Etc so number three you want to use a
tool that is efficient and flexible
and again we we designed macro factor
with that in mind obviously but the
reason there is you want to minimize
friction in the process of diet tracking
there are a lot of folks who
recognize the utility and the value of
diet tracking so they begin it but then
they notice that the friction in the
actual process of tracking their diet uh
kind of dissuades them from
participating in that habit or behavior
over time so they're not doing the
behavior as consistently as they
intended The Habit doesn't really form
because there is this level of
inconsistency in their tracking
practices so if you're using a tool
that's very efficient and very flexible
it can accommodate uh whatever you're
trying to use it for and it can make the
process efficient enough that you
facilitate habit formation in a way that
is not overly strenuous and doesn't
really just tax your ability to will
your way through a bunch of inefficient
and tedious processes number four you
want to use a tool that does not thwart
your psychological needs
um so when we talk about
self-determination Theory we talk about
competence relatedness and autonomy you
want to use a tool that's not making you
feel super
um incompetent you know making you feel
like you're you're messing up your diet
all the time and that you keep screwing
up and you're not making satisfactory
progress you want to use a tool that is
supportive rather than punitive in terms
of the feedback that it gives and even
just the basic Design Elements you know
you don't want to open up an app that
all of the design elements are telling
you that you've messed up in 30
different ways today
um you know it's it's good for an app to
tell you where you can have areas for
improvement but you don't want to feel
like every time you open your phone
you're being punished or scolded
obviously
um and then when it comes to autonomy
like I said you want a tool that's going
to be flexible enough that you really
feel like you're in charge you're in
control you're pulling the levers to
make this thing work which is going to
facilitate intrinsic motivation because
you are the person who is actually
dictating where the path is heading and
you you want to make sure that this tool
in addition to not thwarting your
psychological needs you want to just
make sure that it's not going to stifle
your self-efficacy or your motivation
you know there are a lot of diet
tracking tools that have these very uh
very harsh and very demotivating
um elements that really detract from
your sense of self self-efficacy the the
general intrinsic belief that you
actually can accomplish what you're
intending to accomplish here and then
the fifth thing that you want to focus
on to make your diet tracking as
effective and as enjoyable as possible
is that you want to practice what we
call flexible cognitive restraint now
this has been discussed on the show many
times but the short version is
flexible cognitive restraint is the
opposite of rigid cognitive restraint
and with rigid cognitive restraint you
are likely to dichotomize outcomes and
and make determinations accordingly so
someone who's tracking their diet with
rigid cognitive restraint
might say I have a calorie Target and
I'm either going to hit it perfectly or
I'm going to fail
and the more that you have you know
Monday Tuesday Wednesday fail fail fail
you know if you're setting this really
narrow margin for success and you're
dichotomizing everything you do in very
simple terms as either success or
failure you're probably going to stack
up a lot of failures and it's probably
going to be very demotivating it's
probably going to threaten your
self-efficacy generally not what you
want to do and it also forces you into
rigid protocols that are not very
flexible or sustainable so if you have a
specific set diet with a set calorie
Target and totally specified food
sources at every single meal how are you
going to go out to dinner with a family
member or go to a birthday party or a
work event are you going to have the
flexibility to deviate from the set plan
or
every time you deviate are you going to
categorize that entire day as a failure
if you're categorizing just the smallest
events as categorical failures that's
probably not going to be good for your
long-term success with whatever goal
you're approaching
so flexible cognitive restraint is the
opposite of that we try not to
dichotomize things as pass or fail you
know success or total failure what we're
trying to do there is say I have a
calorie Target and every day I'd like to
get close to that and some days I'll be
closer than others but generally
speaking over time I want to be pretty
close to it most days of the week most
days of the month most days of the year
and you might also another example would
be I've got a calorie Target but I've
also got a target for carbohydrate fat
and protein I would love to get close to
my my specific targets for carbs fats
and protein but they're going to be days
where I say you know what I just want to
get enough protein and make sure that
I'm not going way off with my overall
calorie Target the exact numbers carb
fat and protein we can have some
flexibility and let those fall where
they may now I don't want to
consistently have a very extreme uh
macronutrient distribution that's
incompatible with my goals but if most
of the time I'm doing pretty good with
my calories and my protein I can let the
other stuff fall in place and have faith
that I'm making really big strides
toward my goals Okay so
what you want to do is practice this
flexible cognitive restraint so that you
have some wiggle room to have minor slip
ups that don't become massive failures
or snowball into prolonged instances of
you know non-adherence to your diet or
to your goals and there are some
specific strategies that you can
Implement that that lean on flexible
cognitive restraint so you can do things
like a planned hedonic deviation where
on a particular day of the week or a
particular day of the month you are kind
of allocating some extra calories to
that day allocating a little bit of
extra flexibility so that you can you
know enjoy a day of eating that is
atypical relative to the norm but
because it's part of your plan you know
that you're still feeling good still
still working toward the goals that
you've set for yourself another one
would be a slack with a cost strategy
and what we could call this in the
context of dieting is basically a
calorie Reserve so it's easiest to
explain this in the context of weight
loss you might say you know every day
I'm going to shoot for a calorie Target
of 1900 calories but every week I've got
this extra little this extra little
calorie Reserve that is just these 500
calories that are floating around now if
I want to tap into that Reserve I can do
it but I know that the more I tap into
it the more it's going to broadly
speaking slow my rate of weight loss
right so you're going 1900 calories a
day but there might be a day where you
say you know what I'm just going to take
that whole calorie reserve and today
instead of 1900 we're going to do 2400.
or you might notice that there are a
couple instances throughout the week
where you feel like snacking and so
maybe you add uh you know a 200 calorie
snack there a 100 calorie snack there
you don't use the entire Reserve but you
have not you know gone beyond the
reserve so the idea is that you've got
this calorie Target that's compatible
with your goal you've got this extra
reserve of calories that you can tap
into as needed if you wish to but there
is still a finite limit to how many
calories are in that Reserve budget and
you can allocate the the calories within
that budget however you see fit so there
are a lot of different ways that you can
approach flexible cognitive restraint
but generally speaking it's a pretty
good idea for dieting
um all right so in the show notes I am
going to link some helpful resources
um one is going to be an article about
goal setting another about Behavior
change and then another is going to be
about cheat meals and within that that
article I talk about planned hedonic
deviation slack with a cost and I talk a
little bit more about diet motivation
more broadly in that article
so now that I've discussed some
psychological elements of diet tracking
I think it's important to address a
really critical question which is does
Diet tracking or calorie counting cause
eating disorders this is a really common
concern and a lot of people worry that
if they tell someone to track their food
intake their calories or their macros
you know perhaps it might be a very
risky thing to tell someone in the sense
that it could cause an eating disorder
or or you know some degree of
unfavorable disordered eating behaviors
or habits now this concern is largely
driven by cross-sectional research
reporting correlations right so what
they tend to find in these
cross-sectional studies is when they
look at a group of individuals with
eating disorders and a group of
individuals without eating disorders the
prevalence of diet tracking seems to be
higher in the group of people who have
eating disorders
and that's informative and it's
important to know but it actually
doesn't tell us what we're really
interested in so our research question
or our practical question is not do
people with eating disorders track their
intakes more frequently than people
without eating disorders our real
question here is if I tell someone to
track their diet am I going to cause an
eating disorder for them and so when we
look at this correlational
cross-sectional research it doesn't
actually tell us about the causative
chain of events you know it's very
possible that the prevalence of diet
tracking is higher among people with
eating disorders because having an
eating disorder makes you more
interested in closely observing and
manipulating dietary factors so it's
possible that having an eating disorder
makes someone more likely to track their
diet intake but of course the the
opposite could be true theoretically
that you know the reason we see this
high prevalence of tracking among people
with eating disorders is because they
started tracking and it gave them an
eating disorder so in order to really
figure out the causative nature of this
relationship
you know does does Diet tracking cause
eating disorders uh do Eating Disorders
cause diet tracking or is there a much
more complicated relationship between
the two in order to get to the bottom of
that we want to lean on studies that are
prospective in nature and ideally we'd
love to lean on randomized controlled
trials and fortunately there was a 2021
study by Han and colleagues which
investigated this specific question in
the form of a prospective randomized
controlled trial so basically they
recruited a bunch of people at Baseline
who were not diet tracking randomly
assigned them to groups one group
tracked their diet and their calories
and their macros the other group did not
and they were able to see what was the
actual effect caused by instructing
someone to track their diet their
calories and their macros for a month's
time so for this study they recruited
200 female college students who like I
said were not tracking their diet at
base line and they randomly assigned
half of them were going to track their
their diet in a phone app half of them
were just going to continue doing their
normal thing
the individuals in this study
were not given a goal it was not like
hey you lose five pounds or maintain
your body weight or gain five pounds
they just said hey track what you eat
and drink there's no goal pertaining to
weight loss or weight gain but they just
uh they gave them an estimate of their
energy needs based on a validated
equation one of the ones that that I
addressed previously just kind of put in
some basic information and it pops out
here's how many calories you probably
burn on a daily basis so they knew their
estimated energy expenditure but they
were not told to actively pursue any
specific goal pertaining to weight loss
or a weight gain
now I mentioned that they sampled female
college students and this is a specific
population where we tend to see higher
than average prevalence of disordered
eating symptoms and eating disorder
diagnoses so it's important to recognize
that before enrolling people in this
study they did a a they used an eating
uh an eating disorder questionnaire and
that allowed them to exclude
participants who already had pretty
concerning levels of eating disorder
symptoms at Baseline so they're able to
see you know people who are already you
know kind of in a Range that would be a
bit concerning in terms of eating
disorder symptoms they were able to
exclude them before putting them into
the study
and you might consider that to be a
limitation in the sense that the people
most likely to develop an eating
disorder from tracking were excluded but
it's really the only ethical way to do
this type of study
um you know you cannot do a study where
you say hey we want to know if this
causes a pretty serious uh you know a
very serious medical condition and we
think you're predisposed to that medical
condition so we'd love to see what
happens you know that's that's not an
ethical thing that you can do in the
world of human research so it was
absolutely a critically necessary step
because Eating Disorders are not
something to be you know not something
to take lightly so they were able to
identify on the front end people who
were already very highly predisposed to
eating disorders and to make sure that
they were not put in a situation where
those eating disorder symptoms could be
exacerbated or Amplified by the
intervention
so in terms of the results uh the
researchers did not observe any
significant negative effects on eating
disorder risk anxiety depressive
symptoms body satisfaction quality of
life eating behaviors physical activity
screen time or other forms of
self-related or weight related
self-monitoring so what they found was
you know for individuals who were not
already very highly predisposed to
eating disorders at Baseline
um you know telling them to track their
dietary intakes with a phone app did not
negatively impact psychological outcomes
or apparent eating disorder risk on the
other hand I should acknowledge as I
noted previously the mere Act of
tracking one's diet didn't really do
much in terms of other health related
behaviors or outcomes so much as we
would expect just telling someone hey
write down what you eat and drink it did
not lead to some spontaneous Improvement
in health or Fitness level or anything
like that but the bright side here was
that diet tracking did not induce did
not appear to induce any negative
psychological outcomes or any
amplification of eating disorder risk
and so what that tells us is Diet
tracking can be extremely helpful but
merely tracking is not going to get the
job done you need to make sure that
you're tracking for a reason you're
tracking with purpose
and you're actually doing something with
the numbers that you receive from the
the practice of dietary tracking
um you know diet tracking based on the
research we have does not seem to cause
eating disorders or symptoms of Eating
Disorders however like I said that
randomized controlled trial did exclude
people at Baseline who had a heightened
risk of eating disorder development and
so I think it's really important that
before someone chooses to track their
diet that they think very closely about
their perceived susceptibility to eating
disorders and the risk of eating
disorder symptoms if I had someone who
was you know
if I was conversing with someone in an
informal way obviously I'm not a
clinician or or a medical doctor so I
couldn't give this type of advice but if
I was informally conversing with a
friend who said yeah I've been thinking
about tracking my diet but you know here
are six very concerning you know diet
really related behaviors I already have
you know if I'm talking to someone and I
get the sense that they might already
have an undiagnosed eating disorder or
are just on the verge in terms of a
really heightened predisposition I would
I would encourage them to speak with a
professional before they embarked uh on
into the practice of tracking their diet
so predisposition at Baseline is really
important to have a um to keep in mind
before someone considers diet tracking
but the research would tell us that for
people who are not already predisposed
to eating disorders or for people who
don't already basically have an
undiagnosed eating disorder the act of
diet tracking does not seem to
spontaneously cause disordered eating or
clinically relevant Eating Disorders
once again
if you want to further minimize the risk
of negative of having a negative
psychological experience there are some
best practices that you can lean on and
again this is coming from an educational
perspective I'm not a counselor I'm not
a psychological uh I'm not a medical
professional trained in Psychology but
based on the research it looks like if
you're trying to avoid the likelihood of
a negative psychological experience with
diet tracking you probably want to
implement flexible cognitive restraint
you probably want to use a tool that's
not going to fuel any shame or any
catastrophizing if you slip up with your
diet targets and you probably want to
use a tool that's not going to thwart
your basic psychological needs or stifle
your sense of self-efficacy and your
sense of motivation
foreign
as the first and only Fitness podcast
with a steadfast commitment to
traditional Family Values we know that
protecting families is important right
you are Eric but I will note there are
some things that are even more important
than predicting traditional family
values and the moral fabric of our
society that's right Greg it's important
to protect families but it's even more
important to protect corporate entities
that's why I joined the Advisory board
for the Sports Nutrition Association
Along with trusted Fitness Pros like
Danny Lennon and distrusted arch nemesis
like Eric Helms the Sports Nutrition
Association is the home of Sports
Nutrition they are dedicated to ensuring
the sustainable prosperity of the Sports
Nutrition profession and they offer a
unique Pathway to robust insurance
coverage for your Sports Nutrition
business simply put it's the best way to
protect the corporate entities that are
closest to your heart and I should note
if you're an individual soul proprietor
providing Sports nutrition services and
not a corporate entity the Sports
Nutrition Association can help you out
as well that is correct all insurance
plans are handled individually on a
case-by-case basis regardless of how
your Sports Nutrition business is
structured but even if you don't want
insurance coverage sna membership comes
with a bunch of other perks and
advantages the Sports Nutrition
Association is the only Global
professional sports body that has a
defined standard for Sports Nutrition
scope of practice for its members this
ensures that members maintain high
standards in their practice so that the
public can always trust in the quality
associated with the services of an
accredited Sports nutritionist through
the Sports Nutrition Association if you
already meet their minimum education
requirements you can become an
accredited Sports nutritionist today if
you don't meet those education
requirements yet you can enroll in the
certificate program in applied Sports
Nutrition that allows you to become a
provisionally accredited member upon
completion to learn more about the
Sports Nutrition Association head over
to
www.sportsnutritionassociation.com today
today's episode is sponsored by the
Sports Nutrition Association and
stronger by science LLC sincerely
appreciates their support
so that's all great we know that diet
tracking can be helpful but you got to
do it right and you got to make sure
you're doing it in a way that's going to
be good for your your general
psychological temperament but
a relatively newer thing that or it's
not new but it's getting more popular
more common in the Fitness World you
might have heard that mindful eating is
an alternative to diet tracking that
more directly Embraces self-compassion
and might be a better alternative to
diet tracking there are a lot of
misconceptions about mindful eating and
so as we're talking about diet tracking
I wanted to cover some of those
misconceptions and talk about what
mindful eating actually is so one of the
most common questions that comes up is
you know can mindful eating and macro
tracking
can they actually coexist uh and a lot
of folks will tell you no but I very
strongly disagree with that perspective
and in this segment I'll tell you
exactly why
but before we get there
um
it's important to discuss uh what
mindful eating actually is it's become
very it's become increasingly popular in
recent years in many cases it is
presented as a strategy that is
inherently linked or perhaps even
synonymous with intuitive eating in some
cases it's framed as being an
alternative to structured diets or macro
tracking and not just an alternative but
an alternative that is mutually
exclusive you have to either do mindful
eating or do a structured diet or do
diet tracking so let's first talk about
what mindful eating actually is
um it is not the same thing as intuitive
eating they are often implemented in
combination with one another but they
don't necessarily need to be so there
was a great systematic review
by Grider and colleagues which I'm going
to link in the show notes where they
they Define both of these terms so they
defined intuitive eating as eating with
an intentional focus on physiological
hunger and satiety cues rather than
external cues to guide intake and they
further elaborate that external cues
could include emotions food availability
seeing or smelling food social settings
where eating is encouraged serving sizes
or food packaging and they also
mentioned that intuitive eating it
basically seeks to train an individual
to focus on responding to their physical
Sensations in order to determine their
body's needs so rather than going off of
a script for what they ought to be
eating they're kind of taking stock of
their physical Sensations and then
making a determination about what they
ought to be eating based on their body's
needs
now mindful eating is neither the same
nor the opposite of intuitive eating it
is a completely separate completely
distinct topic and distinct concept
altogether uh so mindful eating is not
about what you eat or when you eat or
why you eat mindful eating is very
explicitly about how you eat so it's not
about how you diet but it's about how
you approach the process of actually
ingesting foods and beverages so Grider
and colleagues uh in that systematic
review reviewed they Define mindful
eating as the act of paying attention to
food during consumption and having
awareness and focusing on the experience
with food there's an alternative
definition provided in a paper by Joseph
B Nelson which I'll link and that
definition is paying attention to our
food on purpose Moment by moment without
judgment which frames mindful eating as
an approach to food that focuses on an
individual sensual awareness of the food
and their experience of the food and
then Nelson goes on to clarify that the
intention of mindful eating is to help
individuals Savor the moment and the
food and encourage their full presence
for the eating experience so as you can
see these concepts are not mutually
exclusive but they are very distinct
intuitive eating
is largely focused on leaning on hunger
and satiety cues to make a determination
about what when and how much you should
eat in contrast mindful eating like I
said is about how you approach the
actual Act of eating the process of
consuming a food or a beverage and so I
think a natural question to ask is well
then
how exactly does mindful eating work
like what would that look like in
practice and the general idea so there's
actually a step-by-step example in the
paper by by Joseph Nelson that I linked
uh in the show notes here but the
general idea for the actual
implementation of mindful eating is that
it's a very focused form of eating so
the purpose is to eat in a
non-distracted manner while very
intentionally directing your full your
your full attention your full Focus to a
number of very pertinent focal points
during the eating process during the act
of eating so for example
as you're sitting down to eat something
you might Begin by taking stock of what
your current emotional experience is uh
you know am I feeling content happy sad
stressed anxious
Etc
um and you might take a moment to
consider how that might impact what you
are choosing to eat uh how much you're
putting on your plate you know you you
want to take stock of that and think you
know
just from an observational perspective
how is that emotional state impacting
this experience of eating and how is it
impacting my dietary habits in this
moment so you'll take stock of your
emotional experience takes stock of how
your body is feeling
you'll also take stock of some of the
characteristics of the food uh you know
so you might think about uh how it feels
how it smells
um how uh you know how it looks you know
really immersing yourself in the
experience of eating and taking stock of
you know the the overall broader
experience of of consuming this food and
you might even take it a step deeper
you know so um when you hear about
mindful eating being described from
people who are uh practitioners of
Buddhism uh you'll often hear people
talking about thinking about where the
food comes from you know and not just
what restaurant did you get it from or
what grocery store but what does the
process look like for this food to
Simply come to be uh what does it look
like for you know if you're talking
about a raisin you know for the soil and
the rain and the sunlight to combine to
actually grow a grape and then for
someone to pick that grape and for that
grape to be made into a raisin and for
that raisin to find its way to your
grocery store and for you to do a
transaction to acquire that that raisin
you know there's this whole chain of
events that leads a food to the eating
experience and with mindful eating
you're just kind of immersing yourself
in the experience of eating and looking
at it from all angles and it's very
possible that this approach to eating
and even this General approach to
thinking feels very unfamiliar to you
and I think it's important to recognize
the context of of mindful eating and
some of its basic Origins so
mindful eating is derived from the
broader concept of mindfulness and John
Cabot Zinn defines mindfulness as paying
attention in a particular way on purpose
in the present moment and
non-judgmentally and the uh the the
roots of this kind of General
contemporary secular approach to
mindfulness practice are mostly traced
back to Buddhist teachings
um that that's not the only kind of root
origin some of these mindfulness
Concepts but like I said the the kind of
contemporary secular mindfulness
practices that are becoming more popular
often claim to be you know directly
linked back to uh practices in Buddhism
and more specifically in the school or
the tradition of Zen Buddhism so a deep
dive into Buddhist philosophies and
perspectives certainly beyond the scope
of this nutrition podcast episode
um but if you wish to develop what I
would call a deeper and richer
understanding
of mindful eating and you're you hear
about the concept and you say I this
fully doesn't make sense to me
um it might be worth digging in to some
ideas of Zen Buddhism and as you dig
into the concept of mindfulness as it
pertains to Zen Buddhism you start to
gain uh more perspective on on how
mindful eating came to be and and what
the potential benefits might actually be
um now if you look into the Zen Buddhist
tradition mindfulness is applied to much
more than eating
um you know there are you know in Zen
Buddhism you'll hear people talk about
mindful eating but you'll hear them talk
about mindful walking mindful breathing
mindful sitting uh mindful dishwashing
and you know and everything in between
so mindfulness practice is always
anchored by mindfulness of something and
that something can be whatever you
happen to be doing so in other words I'm
kind of paraphrasing here based on my
own perspective you know I am not a
Buddhist philosopher or a theologian so
just my personal perspective is that
mindfulness is viewed more as a a state
of mind and a quality of focus
that can be applied to virtually all
aspects of somebody's life and So within
that context we can see mindful eating
or mindfulness of eating as being merely
one small application of this broader
set of mindfulness practices so probably
more than you bargained for getting into
a nutrition podcast hearing a little bit
about Buddhist philosophy but I think
it's important if we're talking about
mindful eating and it comes from a
general sense of mindfulness which you
know has roots linking back to Zen
Buddhism I think it's it's informative
to kind of track things back to those
root Origins to gain a better
understanding of why would I sit down
and think about where a raisin came from
uh why would I
why would I perceive value in the
process of eating with a higher love
higher level of focus and attention on
you know the act of eating so that's
where some of this stuff comes from
the question that a lot of people have
on their mind when they hear about
mindful eating is
is this a weight loss strategy and by
definition the answer is no uh you know
it is not a strategy that was designed
to induce weight loss it was not a
strategy that was designed to enhance
adherence to a low calorie diet or
anything like that however some folks
seem to be more frequently these days
suggesting that you cannot use mindful
eating in conjunction with a diet or an
intentional weight loss plan and I hope
that by giving some background on
mindful eating you can intuitively see
that that's categorically untrue uh the
this act of eating in a very focused way
with a great deal of of in of attention
on the eating process can be applied in
a wide variety of eating scenarios and
contexts so
um when we think about the idea of
is mindfulness for weight loss the
answer is obviously no there was nothing
in this background information that
would make it seem to be the case and if
you look at the systematic review I
mentioned by Grider they mentioned uh
when talking about mindful eating the
intent is not weight loss or to restrict
intake but it's believed that if one is
mindful of their food experience and
consumption the result could be that
awareness of how a food is making
someone feel you know that that
awareness would increase and that would
then lead to the selection of healthier
options so as you're more aware of the
eating process and how you're feeling
throughout and how eating is uh
ultimately fueling your body you might
become more aware of the food selections
that you're making and it could lead to
an alteration of dietary habits along
those lines Nelson and the the other
peer-reviewed paper I mentioned
Nelson states the purpose of mindful
eating is not to lose weight although
it's highly likely that those who adopt
the style of eating will lose weight so
weight loss is not the intention uh you
know drastic overhaul of dietary habits
is not the intention but there is
some possibility that when someone does
mindful eating they might notice that
they lose some weight or they might
notice that they start making slightly
different uh choices pertaining to their
food their food intake and their dietary
habits now if we move beyond the
peer-reviewed scientific literature and
Branch out into lay press books we get
even more information about the
relationship between mindful eating and
weight loss so like I said mindful
eating is not a weight loss strategy but
there is room for mindful eating in the
context of a weight loss strategy so if
you are trying to lose weight if you're
trying to adhere to a low calorie diet
you absolutely can Implement mindful
eating as part of that process
um so to provide a little more context
there one of my favorite books about
mindful eating is called Savor and I
actually have it right here with me and
Savor is written by tiknot Han and Dr
Lillian Chang now tiknot Han is a what
was a world-renowned zen master and
Buddhist monk he passed away a little
over a year ago approximately a year ago
I think it's been a little over a year
um but according to Wikipedia uh
technohan is broadly recognized as the
father of mindfulness he played a very
big role in kind of spreading ideas
about mindfulness to the Western World
um and it is a just a tremendously well
respected uh Buddhist monk and zen
master and actually I I've I have many
of his books I probably have two dozen
books that he's written uh so I think
very very highly of tick not Han in
terms of being just a tremendous source
of information pertaining to Buddhism
and mindfulness the other author is Dr
Lillian Chang Dr Chang is a registered
dietitian and is also the director of
mindfulness research and practice at
Harvard's Department of nutrition now
I'm not trying to commit the appeal to
Authority fallacy like I'm not going to
say hey if they say it it is absolutely
factual and true and cannot be contested
but if you're looking for a general
understanding of what mindful eating is
supposed to be uh I think their
perspectives carry a little bit more
weight than your average influencer you
know so the reason I bring this up is
because you'll see people you know with
some random Instagram accounts saying
saying you may not do mindful eating and
weight loss at the same time
or you may not do mindful eating and
caloric restriction at the same time and
if I want to know what mindful eating
can be used for I I will value the
perspectives of someone who's referred
to as the father of mindfulness and
someone who is the director of
mindfulness research and practice at a
you know a prestigious organization
doesn't mean everything they say is
always right in every possible context
but if you're looking for perspectives
on what mindful eating ought to be I
think that their word carries a
tremendous amount of weight and
certainly have a great deal of uh
appreciation for their expertise in this
specific area so uh in this book you
know you might wonder does it shun the
idea of combining intentional weight
loss with mindful eating does it offer
mindful eating as a totally
contradictory alternative to dietary
restriction the answer is absolutely not
um you know for example uh one section
of chapter five there's actually a
subheading that says to control your
weight calories matter okay so
um there are numerous instances within
this book where they talk about the
utility of mindful eating within the
context of energy restriction or weight
loss now they don't say that mindful
eating is designed for that it's merely
the idea that these two things can be
compatible so that's good we've
established that mindful eating can be
used in conjunction with weight loss the
two are compatible
but that doesn't tell us if mindful
eating actually causes or induces weight
loss and when it comes to the scientific
literature in this area we have to
accept some less than ideal conditions
uh specifically when it comes to
definitions and interventions so if you
want to have enough information here to
really sort through in a meaningful
informative way
you have to lean on this broad category
of literature where interventions I
think have been kind of
blurred together and not very well
defined and distinguished from one
another so you're going to see stuff
where mindful eating is part of some
other mindfulness intervention so they
might do some mindfulness sitting
meditation combined with mindful eating
strategies and all this this combined
intervention is kind of rolled into one
uh also you'll see
interventions that are actually
intuitive eating interventions that
include a mindful eating component and
so if we're looking at these systematic
reviews and meta-analyzes on whether or
not mindful eating induces weight loss
we have to accept the fact that when we
talk about these interventions there are
some other elements that kind of Muddy
the waters where it is not specifically
mindful eating but is mindfulness
practices that involve mindful eating
and perhaps even a little bit of
intuitive eating in the mix so I agree
it's a little messy that that's a caveat
I acknowledge on the front end so when
we look at systematic reviews and
meta-analyzes that try to determine if
some of these mindfulness focused eating
strategies uh actually induce or
facilitate weight loss the evidence is
mixed so there is a meta-analysis by our
tiles and colleagues where they found
relatively positive effects in terms of
facilitating weight loss there was also
a systematic review by caterman and call
colleagues where they actually found
inconclusive effects on weight loss from
this kind of blurred cluster of
strategies you know when we talk about
these systematic reviews and
meta-analyzes like I said it's kind of
mindfulness based eating strategies with
like a little hint of intuitive eating
in the mix generally speaking there's
some evidence suggesting that um
you know there could be a positive
effect on weight loss other evidence
suggesting that the the
um the effects seem to be a little bit
mixed and I think some of those mixed
results ultimately come down to two
things first of all when you're blurring
these interventions together it can add
some degree of variability in terms of
what the systematic review or
meta-analysis is actually investigating
um you know so I I would expect some
kind of mixed findings when the actual
intervention is so loosely defined and
implemented and the other thing is with
any type of mindfulness intervention the
implementation is really key
um it's really Critical with any type of
mindfulness-based intervention to make
sure that you're presenting it in a way
that's very accessible a way that the
participants in the trial or the program
are really going to buy into it and
really Embrace some of the ideas because
we're really talking about
we're talking about perspective here and
cognitive processes at the participant
level so if you're not able to deliver
the intervention in a way that really
effectively reaches the individual and
kind of conveys a message of how this is
supposed to really work effectively you
could find uh instances where one
mindfulness eating or one mindful eating
intervention is far more effective than
another mindful eating intervention
purely on the basis of just being
implemented in a much more skillful and
much more effective way so in general it
looks like mindful eating could possibly
facilitate weight loss but probably is
not going to cause a lot of weight loss
on its own uh in the majority of cases
so it could be used as part of a weight
loss strategy but I would not uh adopt
mindful eating
and expect that just doing that alone is
going to cause some precipitous degree
of of weight loss and if you're
wondering why uh mindful eating might
facilitate uh or be a nice
um kind of adjunct intervention that
that can help out with weight loss there
are a few mechanisms that could be at
play so generally speaking mindful
eating encourages a slower rate of
eating right so like I mentioned as
you're eating you're taking stock of
your environment you're taking the stock
of your emotions you're taking stock of
your physical Sensations you're taking
stock of the characteristics of the food
how it's making you feel as you put it
in your mouth and chew it and swallow it
and as you eat more and more you know
there's so much uh perception going on
so many instances to stop and and really
immerse yourself in the experience and
so what that means is typically you're
going to eat more slowly right you're
not just kind of distracted and just
kind of you know shoveling you know
Spoonful after Spoonful you're really
taking the time to savor it and to think
about it and to experience it more fully
and so when when we slow down our eating
rate
a number of things can happen uh first
of all eating more slowly
can influence the the kinetics of the
processes related to our satiety related
hormones right so satiety and hunger are
impacted by some pretty intricate
hormone systems and when we start eating
a meal there is an endocrine response
that involves uh you know increased
levels of these satiety hormones which
make their way to key structures in the
brain which convey the message of
satiety which then influences our desire
to continue eating and so what that
means is if we slow down our rate of
eating we can theoretically give that
Cascade of processes more time to work
and and so uh the the process of getting
the message okay now we are eating and
there's this influx of calories and this
physical food matter and you know then
satiety hormones are going to increase
and they're going to work their way to
the brain centers where they actually
interact with key receptors and kind of
cause this Cascade of events where the
brain starts to understand oh yeah I'm
actually I'm actually quite quite full
at the moment and and quite happy to
discontinue eating
so by slowing down the rate of eating it
leaves a little bit more room for that
Cascade of events to happen uh such that
we might start to notice satiety
increasing before we have reached a very
very high level of caloric intake in
that meal so that's one mechanism a
second mechanism that could be at play
here when we look at mindful eating
facilitating weight loss is the fact
that a slower rate of eating can
influence our memory related to food
ingestion and can also influence our
sensory experience of the meal you know
so we have more time during the meal
where we are really fully experiencing
the flavors and the Aromas of the meal
we are kind of mentally coding that as a
greater sense of satisfaction and a more
prolonged experience in which we are
quite satisfied from a sensory
perspective and so there there is some
interesting Research into indicating
that when you have someone slow down a
meal there's almost we can think of it
as a higher ratio of status sensory
satisfaction relative to calories
ingested and it also seems that there is
a
persistent effect of that that seems to
drag on throughout the day where if we
have this slower eating experience that
leads to Greater sensory satisfaction
per unit calorie we we kind of code that
as a deeper memory of you know at 3 pm
we still kind of remember oh man I had
that really lovely uh very satisfying
meal just a few hours ago at noon uh and
it might at least it appears to
influence our dietary behaviors and
choices in that period of time following
that meal so uh that research to me is
not fully fleshed out I'm going to admit
that on the front end but if we're
looking for explanations of why mindful
eating might lead to
um you know perhaps a slightly easier
weight loss process or even perhaps an
unintentional modest reduction in body
weight
it's possible that that Amplified
sensory experience might impact our
memory of the meal in a way that
persists throughout the day and does
influence some of our dietary choices
and behaviors and then a third
um mechanism that comes to mind is that
mindful eating strategies also tend to
facilitate what we would call an
acceptance-based approach to Weight
Management hunger management and dietary
restraint so
um in fact like just to kind of
reinforce that point there's a really
great published review about
acceptance-based weight control
strategies and it discusses mindfulness
as a key component of this
acceptance-based approach and uh
sometimes with with well always as far
as I know with research papers you're
going to have to specify a number of
keywords and mindfulness was actually
one of the five key words that was
selected for the article so that's just
kind of a a direct demonstration of how
critical mindfulness is is when we talk
about these acceptance-based strategies
so if you're wondering what an
acceptance-based approach would actually
be in this context it's actually a very
intuitive concept so if you're trying to
use an acceptance based approach to
Weight Control
you want to really focus on your
thoughts your feelings and your bodily
Sensations when it comes to the
behaviors pertaining to weight control
so for for our case we'd be talking
about eating or we might be talking
about Hunger Sensations between meals or
something like that and the the idea of
an acceptance-based approach is that
you're taking stock of these experiences
thoughts feelings uh these bodily
Sensations and instead of trying to
suppress them or avoid them or kind of
catastrophizing when a negative one
arises what we're trying to do is kind
of change our relationship to these
experiences and Sensations such that we
can
um basically accept that they are part
of the process and we can almost embrace
the fact that we we understand that
these various Sensations will will come
and go throughout our Weight Control
process so to lean on a more concrete
example here we can think about hunger
uh and how it would look if we adopted
an acceptance-based approach now
typically you know a lot of dieters
really do fear hunger and they
aggressively avoid hunger and sometimes
they do catastrophize a little bit when
hunger is present it's very natural to
be become hungry and say oh man if I'm
hungry now how am I going to feel in
three hours or how am I going to do this
diet if I'm already feeling hungry at
180 pounds and I'm trying to get to 160
you know uh so it's very understandable
why we get to those points where hunger
induces some degree of fear or concern
or worry
um but if we adopt a more
acceptance-based approach we can
mindfully acknowledge the presence of
hunger without kind of falling into
those conditioned responses we can we
can experience that sensation and say
I notice and I acknowledge that hunger's
present I accept that hunger is going to
be part of my experience as I pursue
this goal but I'm not going to let it
take the reins of my perceptions and my
thoughts and my worries I'm not going to
let it derail me
um from an emotional perspective nor am
I going to let it derail me from
my uh my actual dietary goals and
objectives today so we can mindfully
accept the fact that hunger is present
without giving it the power to
completely take control and take the
reins and we're not trying to suppress
it that's a very different thing so
sometimes people will see Hunger arising
or they will notice hunger arising and
they say I need to defeat the hunger or
suppress the hunger
um or find a way to rectify the hunger
and make it go away with an
acceptance-based approach you can say oh
I see that there's some Hunger here and
that's okay uh I expected that this
would be coming to some extent and this
hunger does not have unlimited power
over me and my feelings and the way I
act moving forward so it's not about
suppressing it it's not about overcoming
it it's about accepting it we can kind
of think about it as receiving severely
negative feedback from someone whose
opinion we don't necessarily value all
that much you know we could say Okay I
accept that you think I did a terrible
job uh I can acknowledge that but
ultimately that's not going to ruin my
day or alter the way that I move forward
with the way I do what I do
uh so another example would be a food
craving right so food cravings for a
Dieter can be very stressful
um you know we can notice a food craving
arising and say oh I need to do
something about this this craving has
now kind of taken the reins and and
dictated that now I need to either
suppress or satisfy this craving but
there is another option if we adopt a
very acceptance-based approach we could
we can acknowledge that a food craving
is present and we don't have to satisfy
the craving we don't have to suppress
the craving we can co-exist with the
craving and again you know a simple kind
of analogy that comes to mind is just
getting a piece of feedback or advice
that doesn't emotionally impact you
doesn't change the way that you plan to
proceed moving forward you can
acknowledge that the feedback has been
provided But ultimately it's not really
altering your your perspectives your
emotions or your plan of action as you
continue uh with what you're trying to
pursue
um so we can very clearly see that if
you dig into the broader concept of
mindfulness and you look at how
acceptance-based strategies
um are implemented we can see that
there's a considerable degree of overlap
so where that leaves us when we talk
about mindful eating is once again this
is not designed to be a weight loss
strategy but it's a strategy that could
theoretically induce some modest weight
loss in the right circumstances or it
could make a weight loss goal uh
slightly more enjoyable or slightly more
feasible or palatable it could alleviate
some of the issues that we often run
into during a during a pre-planned
intentional weight loss phase
and the main mechanisms there are you
know through slower eating we might have
altered uh satiety hormone kinetics
through slower eating we might have an
altered sensory experience and an
altered memory of meals and then um
because of that overlap between
mindfulness and acceptance-based
strategies we might be in a position
where we can more effectively cope with
some of the things that often derail a
dieting effort uh things like hunger
things like food cravings we might be uh
mentally in a better position to to move
forward effectively when those things
arise
um so we've we've solidified the point
that mindful eating is not a weight loss
strategy
but you might wonder I mean what what
exactly is it for if if someone wasn't
sitting around saying hey I'm going to
build a weight loss plan and it's called
mindful eating what is mindful eating
actually for what is it supposed to do
and what does it actually do in the
research so in terms of what it ought to
do that's really going to depend on who
you ask
um so if you were to ask a Zen Buddhist
uh what is the purpose of mindful eating
it's very likely that they would reply
that you know being mindful of the
present moment uh is inherently
beneficial for its own sake whether
you're eating walking breathing washing
the dishes uh like I said mindfulness is
often viewed as a way to live life more
fully more clearly and more deeply from
moment to moment so I think a very
common Zen Buddhist perspective at least
as I perceive it uh from studying it is
that mindfulness is good for its own
sake it is a window to help us live our
life with more awareness in a way that
is that is essentially Fuller we are
more fully experiencing the moments that
we live if we are able to lean on a a
mental state that really keeps
mindfulness front and center
now if you ask a nutritionist a
dietitian or even a psychologist with
expertise in eating Behavior they might
reply that mindful eating as in you know
as kind of a intervention is intended to
have beneficial effects pertaining to
more behavioral and psychological
elements of eating and might help
someone improve their relationship with
food now a few years ago that term
relationship with food came up so much
in the fitness world and I would see so
many people talking about I have a good
relationship with food a bad
relationship with food you should
improve your relationship with food but
I actually didn't see a lot of content
about how that's done
um and you know sometimes people would
say well just eat more for long enough
and you'll be less fixated on food and
that's in some cases true but when we
look at improving a relationship with
food I think that mindful eating could
theoretically have quite a role there in
terms of thinking about you know
re-contextualizing our actual experience
with food our emotional experience our
sensory experience
um you know and kind of a more
acceptance based approach to our uh our
relation to food on a day-to-day basis
so
if we look at the evidence though and we
want to say okay does mindful eating
actually change any psychological
elements of eating uh that's a little
more straightforward when I was talking
about the evidence pertaining to weight
loss it's pretty mixed but when it comes
to psychological effects there actually
are quite a few systematic reviews and
meta-analyzes pointing toward quite
positive effects so catterman and
colleagues they found that
mindfulness-based eating interventions
led to reductions in binge eating and
emotional eating you and colleagues
reported reductions in emotional eating
external eating binge eating weight and
shape concerns along with some potential
improvements related to self-acceptance
and emotional regulation
also there have been some positive
changes related to eating behaviors
depression anxiety eating attitudes BMI
and metacognition outcomes based on a
paper by Rogers and colleagues and one
researcher is also speculated kind of
more of a hypothesis that mindful eating
could potentially
alleviate some
stress-induced digestive issues but but
certainly a lot more researchers needed
to substantiate that hypothesis but the
idea is that mindfulness-based
interventions are usually quite
effective for alleviating stress and the
idea is if you have a stress-induced
digestive issue perhaps mindful eating
would be a an effective way to to try to
navigate that that challenge
so in summary there is a pretty
substantial amount of scientific
evidence suggested that
mindfulness-based eating interventions
can positively impact several outcomes
pertaining to the psychological side of
eating you know it's possible that some
weight loss could occur but generally
speaking when we talk about mindful
eating I think the the area of
application with the most promise and
the most potential is more on the
psychological side of eating
perspectives and eating behaviors once
again I just want to reiterate
I'm not a medical doctor not a
registered dietitian and not a trained
uh professional in the field of
psychology so this is not medical advice
but this is just kind of an
evidence-based look at the literature to
date so wrapping things up here you know
just to kind of directly address the
question can mindful eating and macro
tracking coexist it's kind of where this
all started and then we got into
discussions about what is mindful eating
uh can it you know exist in the context
of weight loss does it actually induce
weight loss if not what is it really
induce what is it really for but now I
want to get back to that initial jumping
off point which is can mindful eating
exist within the context of calorie
tracking or macro tracking uh and the
the answer is absolutely so like I
mentioned in this book by by uh tiknot
Han and Lillian Cheng Dr Chen uh in this
book there is some direct information
Nation about how to kind of incorporate
the two
the book goes into some detail about the
utility of monitoring your own habits in
terms of tracking body weight and and
tracking your dietary intakes so
categorically unequivocally it would be
inaccurate to suggest that there is a
consensus that mindful eating and macro
tracking are incompatible or that you
are not allowed to mix the two and in
fact I would say that some of the more
authoritative Authorities on the matter
actually directly embrace the idea that
the two uh can be combined and I think
the way that they are combined is is not
just permissible but I actually view it
as being quite complementary I think
that the two approaches actually go hand
in hand quite well and have a bit of a
synergistic relationship so when we look
at macro tracking
we can use macro tracking to get
objective data on our dietary intakes
and that can inform some of the
qualitative insights that we get from
Mindful eating and conversely with
mindful eating we're getting all of
these qualitative insights we're getting
some subjective data that we can use to
inform the quantitative insights that we
get from macro tracking so you can see
this kind of circular Loop where macro
tracking is providing objective data to
inform our qualitative insights from
Mindful eating and mindful eating is
providing subjective data to inform the
quantitative insights that we get from
macro tracking so uh from my perspective
it's a very complementary relationship
it doesn't mean you have to do both you
could do one or the other
um but I I am uh I I very strongly
disagree with the common perspective
that you have to choose one or the other
I I just don't see the um
I don't see the justification for that
if you actually dig into the roots of
where mindful eating comes from and what
it appears to do within the literature
so just to give some examples of how you
might use these in a complementary
fashion uh first imagine that you're a
mindful eater who has decided that you
want to start incorporating macro
tracking so you're starting from you
know doing uh you know mindful eating on
a regular basis and you're going to add
in macro tracking um so previously you
were able to interpret your subjective
experiences related to your diet habits
but now you've introduced a method that
will allow you to kind of Link those
subjective experiences to some more
objective feedback so you can make even
more nuanced
um uh determinations about how certain
eating environments or mood States or
food choices or subjective experiences
are actually impacting the nuts and
bolts of your diet
now for another example imagine that you
are someone who you've been tracking
your diet observationally right so what
that means is you track what you eat but
you're not actually aiming for specific
calorie targets or macro targets
throughout the day
um if you're starting from that place
you have some Quantified objective
dietary data but you don't really have
any subjective context about how these
numbers are being influenced by things
like your eating environment your mood
State your food choices and all these
other subjective elements so you can see
what you're doing but you don't have
access to the observations about the
subjective experience underlying some of
those choices that you're gravitating
towards so of course if you implement
mindful eating in that context now you
have a more contextualized more
comprehensive understanding a more
well-rounded picture of your overall
dietary habits and so you're getting
this this uh additive information from
Mindful eating
that helps you better contextualize the
observations that you're seeing in your
food log
now finally for a third example let's
imagine that you're someone who tracks
your diet and you are aiming for
specific pre-planned calorie targets or
macro Targets on a day-to-day basis uh
you might notice
uh before you start mindful eating that
it's harder to hit your Macros on some
days than others or you might notice
that on when you eat a certain food it
makes it way easier to hit your Macros
compared to other food choices that make
it way harder so you might start to
notice like
I'm aiming for the same targets every
day but there seems to be a great deal
of variance and how difficult or how
challenging this is you might want to
lean on mindful eating as a strategy to
again further contextualize what you're
seeing in your food log or what you're
experiencing in the process of trying to
hit your Targets on a daily basis you
might find that if you implement mindful
eating there are certain eating
environments certain mood States or
emotional states certain food choices
that are really impacting the ease with
which your ability the ease with which
you have the ability to hit your dietary
Targets on a daily basis so just from
those examples those three examples we
can clearly see scenarios where macro
tracking can facilitate mindful eating
and mindful eating can also facilitate
macro-tracting macro tracking so there's
this combination of objective and
subjective data that can really merge to
paint a more comprehensive and more
well-rounded picture of a person's
overall dietary habits
so let's wrap up the episode with a
little summary here
um
quantitative diet tracking is a tool no
more no less diet tracking alone is not
going to revolutionize your healthier
physique but diet tracking can provide
useful and actionable data to help you
actually adjust your diet to be more
aligned with your goals for people who
are not already predisposed to eating
disorders it appears that diet tracking
when used with flexible cognitive
restraint Can Be an Effective method to
help you modify your dietary intakes
without inducing disordered eating
symptoms or other negative effects on
Mental Health now when it comes to
mindful eating we addressed a number of
misconceptions in this episode so first
a lot of people say that mindful eating
and intuitive eating are the same thing
that's clearly not the case a lot of
people also say
that mindful eating cannot be
implemented in the context of
intentional weight loss or Diet tracking
and when we look more deeply at what
mindful eating is where it comes from
and how it's actually implemented we can
clearly see that that's not the case and
in fact mindful eating and macro
tracking in the context of weight loss
can be very synergistic as they are used
for different but potentially
complementary purposes so mindful eating
is an evidence-based strategy that may
have beneficial effects pertaining to
behavioral and psychological elements of
eating and could theoretically help
someone improve their relationship with
food
on the other hand macro tracking is an
evidence-based strategy that appears to
effectively facilitate weight management
and the achievement of specific dietary
goals so these two strategies are both
evidence-based but they serve different
purposes and they yield different types
of information
the subjective information that we get
from Mindful eating can inform our our
dietary practices in terms of our macro
tracking and the objective data that we
get from our macro tracking can inform
and contextualize some of our subjective
experiences that we notice during
mindful eating so a lot of times people
wonder which of the two that they should
choose between mindful eating and diet
tracking and I say why choose one when
you can easily utilize both
um having said that there are two major
caveats for this entire episode that I
want to reinforce first of all there are
some people who are particularly
predisposed to developing Eating
Disorders there are some folks who are
at very high risk for eating disorders
or might even have current undiagnosed
eating disorders and these individuals
should not undergo any intervention
involving weight monitoring diet
monitoring or dietary manipulation
without first seeking guidance from a
qual qualified medical professional who
has ample training and experience in the
area of disordered eating
number two people with concerns related
to psychological outcomes as they
pertain to dieting should not
independently use mindfulness-based
strategies as a replacement for seeking
help from a qualified health care
professional if you have concerns about
any psychological outcomes you should
absolutely consult with a qualified
medical professional rather than trying
to Dive Right into self-treating
something with some type of
mindfulness-based practice this is a
very useful set of strategies but it is
not an alternative to seeking important
Medical Care
finally before I end this episode I hope
you'll once again afford me the
opportunity to make yet another
Shameless pitch for macro factor which
is the diet app that Greg and I
co-developed along with an incredible
very talented team of colleagues as you
consider the wide variety of diet
approaches and diet strategies that you
might Implement in the New Year rest
assured macro Factor can facilitate
whatever you're planning to do first and
foremost it is a remarkably fast
efficient and Convenient Food logger
with a huge verified database of foods
and extremely easy workflows for custom
food creation custom recipe creation and
even the ability to share your custom
recipes whatever your food Choice
preferences are macro Factor can
absolutely handle it the coached
programs in macro Factor have several
settings ranging all the way from
ketogenic diets to low-fat diets within
each Macro program you have the
flexibility to choose a protein level
level that is compatible with your
preferences if you want even greater
flexibility you can Branch out of those
coach programs and utilize collaborative
mode and then if you want maximal
customizability you can do a fully
manual macro program which gives you the
ability to adjust literally anything
that you would want to adjust within the
app
another important thing about macro
Factor
is that when we designed it we designed
it with psychology research in mind we
wanted to make sure that we were
creating a tool that was efficient so it
would not cause friction when it comes
to behavior change and habit formation
but we also wanted to create a tool that
was very supportive when you look at the
feedback you get from the app when you
look at the design elements everything
was structured in a way so that it would
not thwart your psychological needs and
it would not give feedback using design
elements that would be inherently
punitive or demotivating so macro Factor
truly was designed to be a diet sidekick
it is not interested in shaming you or
punishing you for deviating from a
particular plan it was designed to
provide all the guidance support and
analytics that you need without
infringing on your ability to make your
own decisions and chart your own course
toward your fitness goals so it is
absolutely to design is absolutely
designed to specifically support your
key psychological needs specifically as
it pertains to self-determination Theory
and just good basic principles of habit
formation motivation and behavior change
so if you'd like to learn more you can
check it out at macrofactorapp.com
or you can just search it on one of the
app stores as always thanks for joining
me for another episode of The Stronger
by science podcast we will be back soon
with another
thank you for listening to the stronger
by science podcast if you enjoyed the
podcast be sure to sign up for our free
newsletter to get concise breakdowns of
relevant research as well as 28 free
training programs for all skill levels
and all schedules we hate spam just as
much as you do so we'll only email you
when we have something really
interesting to share with you
you can sign up for the free newsletter
at strongerbyscience.com newsletter or
just go to the stronger by science
homepage and click the free programs
button at the top
if you want to join in on the stronger
by science podcast conversation be sure
to check out our Facebook group and our
subreddit the links for both are
provided in the description of today's
episode
finally please remember that we are not
medical doctors or registered dietitians
so before you make any changes to your
exercise or nutrition habits be sure to
check with a qualified health care
professional once again thank you for
listening and we will be back soon with
another episode of The Stronger by
science podcast
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]